coup sur le terrain
j'entends beaucoup de Français me dire
cela en revanche en revanche faire
croire aux Français qu'on pourrait
régler le problème à long terme du
déficit de système de retraite en
faisant une contribution exceptionnelle
temporaire sur les milliardaires ça me
semble être aussi assez café du commerce
madame foncége si la réalité c'est que
vous signez même dans vos amendements et
l'exposer des motifs la source le
rapport Oxfam j'ai été lire le rapport
d'Oxfam qu'est-ce qu'il dit il faut
abolir les milliardaires donc le projet
c'est pas de régler les problèmes du
système de retraite c'est d'abolir les
milliardaires ça peut être un projet
pour certains je crois pas que c'est ce
qu'on cherche à régler dans ce texte de
loi moi je vais peut-être me répéter je
vais essayer d'aller vite dans la
présidence mais
la France n'est pas un paradis fiscal
pour qui que ce soit ni pour les
entreprises ni pour les plus fortunés ni
pour les moins fortunés on est le
deuxième pays qui taxe le plus dans le
CDE sur les 38 pays on est le dernier
pays européen à avoir un impôt national
sur la fortune 10% des contribuables
payent 70 % de l'impôt sur le revenu en
France il y a une contribution
exceptionnelle sur les revenus qui a été
mise en place en 2010 elle devait être
exceptionnelle et temporaire pour deux
ans ça fait 13 ans qu'elle existe dans
notre pays donc c'est pas vrai de dire
qu'il y aurait un paradis fiscal en
France pour les plus fortunés monsieur
Boca vous avez cité l'exemple de
l'Espagne en disant ils ont mis en place
une contribution temporaire sur les plus
aisées mais précisément l'Espagne n'a
plus d'impôt sur la fortune il y a
quelques années ils ont décentralisé la
compétence de l'impôt sur la fortune aux
régions et qu'est-ce qu'elles ont fait
toutes les régions elles ont toutes
supprimé l'impôt sur la fortune pour
attirer les plus fortunés dans leur
région donc ils partent d'une absence
d'impôt sur la fortune au niveau
national donc ils créent une
contribution temporaire mais nous il se
trouve qu'on a un impôt sur la fortune
déjà en France on est le dernier pays
européen en avoir un national donc
cessons de faire croire qu'on part de
zéro qui n'a pas de fiscalité y compris
sur les plus fortunés en France au
contraire on est ceux qui les taxons le
plus je dis pas là ici je le dénonce pas
ici je dis simplement que 1 il n'y a pas
besoin d'en rajouter et que deux c'est
pas ça qui ne réglera notre problème de
système de retraite
[Applaudissements]